today's topic i feel like twitter might
have like ruined a generation
i have no other way around it so it's an
understatement
i feel like twitter is like a fast food
joint of ideas you have 140 characters
and look that's fine the problem is
people try to tackle complex and nuanced
issues
with 140 characters so you have all
these people on these platforms seeing
their favorite people
put 140 characters on things like
incarceration
on things like police reform on things
like
predatory behavior and what ends up
happening is that you
inherently kill nuance in context
because one everyone wants to be the
first one to get the scoop
and two they have to fit it in those 140
characters
yes they can do subtweets or whatever
but those rarely get
as much traction no so you see the first
week the first weeks kind of pop
and so now that everyone's reading in
140 characters i've realized that people
have started to think in 140 characters
if it takes too long they move on to the
next topic
and you see that with all these like
twitter crusades where they're on one
person for like a day
then they move on to the next person
play the next person and it makes you
realize
that we via social media
have killed the importance of facts and
we've killed the importance
of context you can't tackle a big
problem in 140 characters
because it's like trying to [ __ ]
elephant with a micropinor you know i
why would you want to have a twitter
account
why would you want to do a twitter
crusade i don't understand nothing
and what ends up happening is because
the algorithm is set up a certain way
you end up hearing a lot of the same
opinions that you want
and so in this bid to be like super
inclusive people become like very
exclusive and like the people that they
talk to and they engage with
right and they're like oh we want
diversity people sound super homogeneous
and there's no originality in their
thought process
there's this like weird paradox that you
constantly see and i have a
certain level of discomfort with it
because people act so self-righteous and
then they go about this process of like
condemning people
and they're like yes we believe in
spectrums and all this stuff but you
know what
i saw one thing you did so you're trash
what
what how does that make sense people
you're garbage you're mad what
yo they want you to believe in more
gender identities than there are
characters in a tweet
listen how bro like how do you reconcile
those two existing things
that you will be like oh i believe in
rehabilitation and blah blah blah and
like
let's get the prisoners out and then at
the same time you're so quick to condemn
human beings
off of god damn small instances that you
don't even know the full context of
the thing that they feel to understand
is that trash is a spectrum
trash is a spectrum bro imagine oh abba
you said that in 1992.
yeah well i didn't meet him uh yeah
you're trash and then you reply uh no
i'm on the spectrum
thank you i'm on the spectrum of trash
bruh the same mentality that these
people
have is the same mentality that's been
used to
to criminalize minority communities and
that's facts
on both sides by the way you know what
i'm saying like the way that people like
that's what you are without knowing any
context about that person it's not a
study that i've came up with okay but
it's my perception of things the first
140 characters that you have
and anything that you say is feelings
then
the hud the other 140 characters
is gonna be facts i'm gonna say
even 280. and at the end
you're gonna have the whole context
because you're gonna wrap it up
together and you're gonna do like a
little saint is right
you're going to you're going to bring it
all together 140 character
is the how many celebrities go
and then remove them yeah but it's
already out there we've seen it no no no
no no once we've seen it that agrees
uh we whoo click no no we've seen it
you know what i mean so the one the
first 140 it's just that it's a meme
yeah but the thing with memes is jokes
right and sometimes it's more complex
but it's really seats like the level of
jokes it's like if i try to make a meme
that is indicative of the situation
in palestine i'm only going to scratch
the surface that's the thing
but people revolve and they they try to
do a resolution
a resolution of the whole thinking
with 140 characters even me when on
facebook
where after a certain number of
characters
your you know you can make a background
you can you can make your uh status
a background and stuff like that if
there are certain characters it's too
long it's not going to be a background
like
with colors and stuff like that and you
know i leave it to that
it's just like a quote or something like
that and i got into so many arguments
about things i haven't said i
agree that it ruined a whole generation
i think that every
generation got ruined by something
and us or the generation under
is the social it's not even just that
there's a generation
under it's everybody you know back in
the days when i was generation it was
like
this slab of people but now everybody
from
all those generations whether it's baby
boomers baby boys are being ruined
by twitter millennials exenuals
all the generous they're all ruined so
that's even worse than just like
drugs or this or that or the government
or the cold war it's it's more than that
it ruins
all the generations that deal with that
that's crazy
twitter is just such a cesspool bro i
can't just put it on the social media
platforms i think individuals themselves
have a huge responsibility to think over
the things that they say and the words
that they use
i don't understand people that get
online and talk in a way that they would
never do in real life
like what kind of coward do you have to
be to talk to people online that you
wouldn't say to their face
you sir you talk to me a certain way
online if i see you in real life
you better keep the same energy bro keep
the same energy
i will i and i think that's why i'm not
built for it
is you know how i am it's consistent you
see me at shows
you see me in life you see me in front
of the camera is the same person
yeah but these people who do 180s with
their personality
got so much to say then i go up to them
in person i'm like yo you was talking
all that
crusading stuff let's talk uh well i
don't like confrontation
shut the [ __ ] up then man you want to
fight for a cause when it's convenient
for you you're up
you're a coward i can't stand this
gender no you know what
i'm gonna say it's generation because i
think there's a lot of people who want
to tune out from this stuff but
listen twitter's definitely ruined a lot
of people it's not even a generation
you know what no no i don't take that
back it's i'm not even gonna put twitter
even though the platform doesn't help
you individuals have to take some level
of responsibility for the fact
that you have killed context you know
it's funny how in the
in the end of the 70s it was you know
the death of disco
and now it's the death of content
context
video kill the radio star
video twitter kill twitter posts twitter
posts really
are the junk food of like the idea mark
yeah
the fast food of philosophy so well said
my brother
it's the fast food of philosophy that's
what it is so yo you wanna go uh
you wanna grab a twitter real quick i
got a couple of thoughts i want to put
on
140 characters anyways today is one of
those dates for me i'm sorry bro oh no
it's all good do your thing bro that's
all i got for today you guys haven't
i can't cheer him up but you know this
beat will hit
um
[Music]